what do you want richard could i tell
you something that you did for me that
caused sal to go nuts go ahead you you
had me over for thanksgiving dinner one
time
did i are you crazy
are you crazy
i never had him over where did i have
you it was 2005. we were still at k rock
we did a thing where you broadcast it
from my parents house all day on
thanksgiving that's right and you sent
me a note saying this is so great uh
what are you doing and i was sitting in
my apartment alone
and then you called me and you said hey
why don't you come over and have dinner
with uh me and beth and we went i must
have been out of my mind we went to a
beautiful italian restaurant near your
apartment and uh
it was awesome it was so sweet because i
was alone on thanksgiving and you
thought of me you were like
come over i don't want you to be alone
on
thanksgiving and then jesus
got out i wonder
richard's had thanksgiving dinner with
howard it was a long dinner too we were
there for a couple hours had some drinks
it was great i don't remember it but uh
boy i could see where sal would be in a
[ __ ] oh i remember it
i remember it
every day in the fetal position when i
go to bed at night you sleep a [ __ ]
well you ruined it sal with howard when
you wrote that note that you wanted to
sleep at his house
this is exactly what he told me he goes
listen it's not a big deal i'll stay in
the guest room
i'll take a shower in the morning then
howard and i'll jump in the limo
together and we'll come over i had
visions of us hanging out laughing
watching survivor i was going to cook
for you oh my god in other words like we
could sit and watch tv together
with beth watch survivor we both love it
we both talk about it insane how am i
insane
it sounds like a [ __ ] like doesn't know
me at all doesn't yeah all right i don't
want to talk about this anymore because
it's such a tsunami of complaints and
the truth is you've been you've been
very very very kind to me but i don't
show it off like richard and piss people
off it's funny to watch cell go nuts i'm
gonna go nuts on you after the show he's
gonna put his nuts on your head